- I'm, give it up.
Give it up.
(audience cheers)
- [Nicholas Cage] You guys are great.
You have a wonderful audience.
- Look, even my band.
- Hi, band, hey.
- My band.
(audience cheers)
We're like, so excited.
- I'm happy to be here.
- Dude, I'm telling
you, like, I don't know
if everyone's been this excited.
But, everyone is like, "oh my God".
Like we, you're just so loved.
Everyone loves you.
- Thank you.
You know, Kelly, I've been
wanting to go on your show
because-
- [Kelly] What?
You're the only, talk show interview
who also happens to be a great artist.
- Oh, thank you.
(audience cheers)
- Most of these other
guys are like comedians,
but you're a real, you are massive talent.
- Like a real journalist.
But yeah, no. Oh, you're so nice.
So wait, so you seem so musical
I know that you love music.
- I do.
- Like what's your favorite
kind of vibe to listen to?
- Wow. I mean, I started-
- That's hard to narrow
- I started with my base was classical.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Beethoven, Bach, Brahms
- [Kelly] Love.
- Prokofiev.
And my family, they were
interested in classical music.
My grandfather was a conductor.
He was also the first chair
flutist for Tuscany's orchestra.
- That's awesome.
- So that was, yeah, that was awesome.
And that was the base.
But then I branched out into "The Beatles"
and I got into all, I'm very eclectic.
I love country.
I love early country.
I like Cash.
I love Cline.
I love Campbell.
- [Kelly] Patsy, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh, Glen Campbell.
- Oh, Glen Campbell, yeah.
- Yeah, they're all so great.
- And you, I love the-
- You're so nice. You're nice.
- I just, when I get up in
the morning, I put my head-
- [Kelly] You listen to some KC?
No, I put my headphones
on, I start working out.
I put on, you rock on, "Walk Away".
You just rock.
- Oh!
You actually know one of my songs.
- Yeah. You get me going.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, I
thought you were being funny.
Oh, you're so nice.
- You help me break that extra mile.
Like, I'm gonna do eight miles today.
I gotta put on Kelly's "Walk Away".
And wow.
- You do like, eight miles.
Wow!
(audience cheers)
I wish my music helped
me work out, it doesn't.